hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 3 of the
nikuman Kane athletics Aristotle makes a
very important distinction between what
he calls the voluntary and the
involuntary in greed that you see own
and the acoustical coming from he cone
and aqua meaning the same things apply
it to the person a person is a cone when
they willingly do something when it's by
their own decision or choice when it's
what they want to do and I cone when
they're being you know forced to do it
in some way or it's something that they
don't wanted you so for example when
you're sick and you start coughing right
you may say well I don't really want to
coughing really sorry about that but
it's something that I can't help but do
it
that would be an example of something
involuntary right I poke you in the eye
and you suddenly flinch and probably you
know try to hit me well that's probably
involuntary as well in many respects now
why is this such an important
distinction
well Aristotle says that the voluntary
is what we hold people responsible for
morally so that is what we praise and
blame which is an important function in
Aristotelian as well as other people's
ethics that's what we say is good or bad
on the part of the person
not just the action but the person who
is engaging in the action involuntary
action we let people slide we say well
you weren't really responsible for it
it's not your fault that it turned out
badly or if it actually was good we say
well you weren't really intending to do
the good so you don't get any sort of
reward or crates or anything like that
although people claiming that the good
that they did was involuntary is quite a
bit more rare than the people claiming
the bad that they did was involuntary so
how does Aristotle draw the line between
these there is this a very broad
distinction and then we have to look at
a few nuances to this as well so
voluntary action according to Aristotle
is an action that has its origin its
archaic its beginning it's its principle
you might say in the agent in the person
who's doing it so for example I you know
I'm shooting these videos in part to
help out my students and anybody else
who wants to watch them I am the one who
decided to shoot the videos I set up the
camera I put the stuff on the chalkboard
that's clearly a voluntary action now
what would make it involuntary well
there's one other thing we also to know
what the person is doing they they have
to you know have some conception of what
it is it's intentional right what makes
something involuntary Aristotle talks
about two main ways that things can in
fact be involuntary one of these is when
the action is done out of compulsion and
we've got a whole video about that so
I'm not going to go too deep into that I
do want to say that the way in which we
talk about compulsion today is not quite
what what is meant here a compulsion
does not mean a strong desire to do
something it's rather outside force
intervening and we'll come back to that
in just a moment ignorance is another
thing that can lower or excuse a person
from culpability right lower the amount
of culpability or excuse it
and when somebody has to do something
bad or suffer something bad I would have
a compulsion or ignorance we generally
don't don't say oh you know stupid idiot
you had it coming to you that would be
if we thought it was voluntary we
generally feel sorry for them we feel a
sense of what aerosol calls pity and
we're willing to cut them some slack and
as we say so aerosol doesn't think that
every type of ignorance gets us off the
hook again another core concept video
specifically I'm a I don't have to go
too deep into that let's talk about the
other ones that are a little bit more
easy aerosol talks about so many actions
as being mixed actions are they
voluntary are they involuntary they seem
to be kind of in the middle but he
doesn't say well it's just on a
continuum and they're just in the middle
rather there is a mixture there is an
aspect of them that is voluntary and an
aspect to them that is involuntary this
is really worth dwelling on he talks
about this in particular in relation to
compulsion so he says there there are
some there's something about a actions
done through fear of a worse alternative
we're often placed in situations where
we have to choose not just between say
two Goods and one has to be sacrificed
to another but sometimes which of the
evils that we face are we going to avoid
it which one are we going to in dirt so
he has examples like this the tyrant
having a man's parents and children
whose power commands him to do something
based something ignoble but when he if
he if he complies their lives will be
spared if he refuses they will be put to
death in a situation like that Aristotle
says look you know there are certain
cases where we can call that just
straight out of compulsion when you
cause such a degree of fear that the
ordinary person is not going to stand up
to it
we may excuse that in a case like this
it is voluntary in a way because the
person is choose
to do something in that situation
however in a global sense its
involuntary they did not create that
situation it's actually the voluntary
action of some other guy the tyrants who
presumably you know could choose to do
otherwise who's placing the person in
that situation and we could think of all
sorts of interesting examples of what
we'll come back to with respect to that
in a moment
he says somewhat similar case is when
cargo is jettisoned in a storm
apart from circumstances no one
voluntarily throws away his property but
to save his own life and that of his
shipmates any sane person would do so so
I'd say in these circumstances this is
in fact the right thing to do even
though in other circumstances it
wouldn't be the right or even reasonable
thing to do it's throw away your cargo
we might think for example a situation
that perhaps many of you have
encountered people going through in the
United States TSA checkpoints you're
only allowed to bring certain things on
and if you happen to brought something
that can't go on well you have a couple
choices you can you know make a big fuss
and then you know find out find yourself
in handcuffs you can't say okay I'm
going to leave whatever that is there
and I may be trying to bring in a bottle
of water knowing that you can't have
more than three fluid ounces but you
brought in a big bottle and then they
say you can't have that or you know some
shampoo or all most of the things people
get worked up about in a certain sense
that's that's involuntary right that the
TSA didn't create that situation now in
another set or the TNC created the
situation you didn't create that
situation in another sense if you're
choosing to fly and you presumably can
get the tsa guidelines a heaven a time
that's the kind of ignorance that you're
really culpable for so that is notice
how complicated they can this can get
the action you know is you
is voluntary in a certain respect you
you relinquish the water the TSA is the
larger system imposing some sort of
constraint upon you but you chose to
enter into that so they the arcade the
beginning point of the action really
does in a certain sense live with you
now Arizona says about these the actual
deed in the cases in question has done
voluntarily the origin of the movement
of the parts of the body instrumental to
the act lies in the agent the agent is
actually given some scope for
decision-making for action for
initiating their own action right but
like he says here they're not voluntary
they're they're they're involuntary
apart from circumstances for no one
would choose to do any action any such
action in and for itself and there are
some who Simon Says you know there's
cases where a person is actually praised
for engaging in this sort of action when
you throw them into a situation which
they they don't control and then they
choose to do something that is voluntary
although it's not something they would
choose to do at the time so he says you
know if it's the price of some great or
noble object but he says there seem to
be some action to man cannot be
compelled to dude he really want to
submit to the most terrible death for
example you know killing ones one's
parents or something like that but then
he says it's sometimes difficult to
decide how far we have to go in choosing
to do a given act rather than suffer
given penalty or in during a given
penalty rather than committing a
difficult act going to give an action so
that covers these mixed or both
voluntary and involuntary actions you
notice that we've got Kimba not just a
spectrum here but a place where they
come together and then Aristotle also
talks about some actions being non
voluntary now this is diff
than mixed actions you could say that
they're neither involuntary nor
voluntary there's something different
something neutral something lacking in
in that and what does he have it as an
example their ignorance acts that are
done in ignorance that a person doesn't
like he says feel pain about after
having done them or feel a sense of
regret so things that you do that don't
really have any negative consequences
you would have done them differently if
you would known but it's not a big deal
right you don't feel bad about it
afterwards and and regret that you you
did it those are some actions that we
can I think quite easily relate to
there's quite a large scope of things
that we just don't know and we end up
doing things like you know I took
somebody else's drink by mistake and now
they don't have their drink pals buy him
a new one it's not a big deal right
there's quite a few reactions along
those lines so we have four different
types of actions actions that are
clearly voluntary actions that are
arguably involuntary mixed actions and
non voluntary actions then another
important aspect of this to keep in mind
is that for Aristotle and we're going to
tell you about this is a separate video
responsibility for moral character
virtue and vice are in fact voluntary
why because it's our actions and our
emotional responses and how we do them
when we engage in them then form our
character it's not as if we have
absolute control over our character at
any given time but we do have some so
you know the the Archaea the beginning
point of our character in a certain
respect also lies with us especially
once we become conscious of our own
capacity to shape our character through
the bitumen so we do bare moral
responsibility for the kind of person
that we've become whether we're virtuous
or vicious or a mix of both or somewhere
in
so now we have a good sense of what
Aristotle means by these two very
important terms voluntary and
involuntary you see it covers quite a
lot of ground